- This tastes like happiness.
- It tastes like happiness!
- I don't know what's in a hurricane.
- I'm from Cleveland, Ohio
and we don't have hurricanes there.
- Either people don't know what this is
every time I mention it
or they look like they
have severe flashbacks of
horrible experience with this drink.
- Which makes me super
excited to be drinking this.
- When I see this drink,
I definitely think like
Mardi Gras in New Orleans.
- It smells like what
you drink when you're
like in your first year
in college, I think.
And you're like give me
whatever will fuck me up!
- This is that night where you call up two
ex-boyfriends or girlfriends
that you shouldn't.
- Adios, motherfucker.
- Yeah, adios. Adios.
- Oh I like that.
- Oh boy.
- This tastes like Mardi Gras.
- It's like if Strawberry
Shortcake made an alcohol,
she'd make this.
- The first stage is like sweet
and then like the alcohol punch comes in.
- That tastes dangerous.
- Oh it's good though.
It's like I feel like I'm in Cabo.
- If ice can't even touch it,
it's like Kanye.
- I would love another.
- Of course Kenny had two,
he's such a lush.
- Okay I feel closer to
you after this experience.
- We're now on drink or two.
- Brianna is so cute.
- I feel it like in my thighs.
- Oh my god.
- Do you feel it in your thighs?
- No.
- Well you could dance
with me when you're sober.
- I could dance with
you when I'm sober but
I could dance with you
like all night long.
- Like break it down.
- Like I could be like...
- I just, I feel like my, I feel fidgety
because I wanna dance
and only from this, that's amazing.
- If only the weather phenomenon
was this delicious and
not nearly as devastating.
- Cheers, New Orleans.
- This is beautiful.
- Yes, yes.
- You're beautiful.
Keep up the good work,
you're getting and making people across
the globe happy every day.
- Yes.
- Good job, girl.
- Good job.
- New Orleans, I love you.